guys take out your plastic grass and
marshmallow peeps because in this
episode we're talking about Easter eggs
mind-blowing movie secrets and weird
stuff hidden in movies we watched every
movie of all time from aardvarks
adventure to Zzyzx Road we found all of
this mind-blowing stuff and we're gonna
share with you right now check out the
big brain on Brad Quentin Tarantino's
movies all take place in the same
universe Reservoir Dogs mr. Ron and pulp
fiction's Vincent Vega our brothers red
apple cigarettes and Big Kahuna burger
make multiple appearances in Tarantino
films oh and another thing that's kind
of ubiquitous throughout the Tarantino
universe woman's feet there are a lot of
them Tarantino's a foot fetish and shot
of the dead they summarized the entire
plot of the movie right at the beginning
of the movie it's Ed's plan for the day
we should keep drinking at a Bloody Mary
first Oh Mary I'm warning you oh by the
king's head a couple of the little
princess stand up like you
back at the bar for shot
how's that for slicer front go
subconsciously the whole thing was there
I'm just saying it's a good thing that I
have no access to my subconscious due to
some horribly traumatic childhood events
I fell down a well did you know that the
parade theme at the end of Star Wars
Episode one is the Emperor's theme from
Return of the Jedi just sped up and in a
major key give it a listen
same song we decided to yours
I really can't blame John Williams for
phoning it in on that crap fest I think
they should have thrown a parade when
they stopped making prequels the
numerology of Scott Pilgrim vs. the
world all of the ex-boyfriends that
Scott Pilgrim has to kill that
boyfriend's number is all over the scene
look at all these number - there's a -
there's two things right there there's
the number - look at all these threes
three up there's a three threes three
again guys the only pho that Scott
Pilgrim didn't defeat the box office
didn't do great underrated movie though
and it's not ruined by how twee and
adorkable Michael Cera is but you will
choice you drool little nickels leave a
comment below
what's better my Michael Cera or my Yoda
this next one I like to call Teen Wolf
penis in the final basketball scene a
fan in the stands just has just dick out
oh what'd you do today honey well I was
at the extra on this movie Teen Wolf and
I had my penis outside of my pants I
want to divorce Pixar is the king of
this stuff you're going to lose your
mind looking for all the Easter eggs one
of the most interesting things that they
do a nod to the next Pixar film is
always hidden in the previous woman Nemo
is in Monsters Inc the Paul Newman car
from cars is in The Incredibles and on
and on and on Easter eggs are the Pixar
the same way
hidden porn is to news me go ahead and
give that a search oh you'll have some
fun and number one uh it's screen
junkies there's an older episode where
let's just say I needed a hand you know
what I'm talking about
go look for it also there's an Easter
egg in this very episode
and you find so what's a mind-blowing
movie nugget that you know about that we
didn't mention leave an answer in the
comment section below
best answer but screen doggies t-shirt I
want to thank you for watching screen
junkies I'm Howard day highlight